sir what are we looking at right now uh
seeing robert de niro in person for the
first time
i just want to point out that that is
an icon that's that's robert de niro
i mean that's the reason why half of us
like movies it really is crazy you know
what i mean all right let's let's step
over here
we'll walk right here so i don't like
just geek out and be like yeah the whole
time all right so sir i'm gonna go like
this and oh that's great perfect camera
uh
so i love your movie what is it like
actually to because and i was talking to
joseph about this it's really hard for
like everyone to like something
and everyone loves the movie so what is
that like
um
oh sorry
um
it is uh it just makes me feel so great
i mean obviously you talking to joe is
like
joe put everything into this movie i
mean joe
is probably singular in the fact that he
could pull off a movie like this like
with his entire mechanical engineer
brain
mixed with
his his cinematic brain mixed with his
ability to communicate emotions to
people it's like
i don't know if there's anybody else
that could have done this like joe it's
just it's really amazing to see and i'm
not sure we could pull this movie off
without tom cruise having a 40-year
career of pushing the limit of cinema
and so it's just i don't know i just
feel so lucky to be a part of it really
really
a movie that for me is emblematic of
what
great movies are about and what the
theatrical experience is about so um and
not to mention everybody on this i think
is so nice they're wonderful they're
just it's just it's just great it was it
was
just charm from start to finish it was
challenging in a lot of ways in terms of
just physically what we had to do but
i just feel so grateful to be a part of
it and you're right to
have something that everybody responds
to is the odds are like joe said it's
hitting a bullet with a ball
oh it's it's to quote the movie it's a
miracle it's a miracle on top of another
miracle right exactly so i do want to
actually specifically the cinematography
and the the visuals in the movie are
incredible what was it actually like
working on the film in terms of the
actual cinematography and the cameras
being in very specific places and all
that stuff well you know the interesting
part is we had to sort of honor the
legacy of tony scott these long lenses
you know his style his visual style was
so cool and rich and dynamic um and yet
you have joe kosinski and claudio
miranda that team
is so um
is so like potent in what they can do
with the camera and the emotion
that they can get out of a lens the
emotion they can get out of them so when
you're working at that level it's just
it's just like nothing you've ever seen
before i mean these guys are
the best in the business so um as an
actor it feels incredible being on the
other side of that lens you feel very
taken care of uh what is the day from
filming that you were like we are never
gonna get effing through this this is
impossible what are you talking about
we're not doing this oh my gosh uh you
know
to to hold a flex during that football
scene
i'll tell you to flex for hours
it's golden you know golden hour sure
it's like you know covered in coconut
oil trying to throw a a greased up
football it's it's tough yeah that
that's uh yeah uh my last thing for you
um
i guess
uh what has it been like for you and i
mentioned this to you earlier but like
you're you're great in this movie and
it's like you have to wait like you know
forever years for this thing to come out
what has it been like for you waiting
for this movie to come out you know it's
it's it's been an emotional experience
because you
as you say it's like
we did something that i feel like is
next to impossible we made a movie that
i feel like the world
at large is going to absolutely love
that it's going to just blow the doors
off of everyone so when you have
something that you've seen that you're
like
we did it this is incredible this is
this
this is everybody's going to love this
and then you have to hold on to it it's
like holding on to the greatest secret
of all time it's really
it's a it's a hard thing and also um
you just you just i'm so glad
i wouldn't have had the same
stomach so hold on to it hold on to this
like tom did tom was like hold on to it
be patient there's gonna be a great time
for this movie and on the other side of
this pandemic we're gonna get to show
the world this thing in its full glory
and i'm really glad we waited because i
really feel like the world is ready for
us